Everybody should be able to be
made fun of everybody's going
to take a joke.
And if you can't don't watch it
media comedians going to offend
everybody in any way I mean
that's his job you can't take
everything to heart honestly
they're making fun of one
specific group is off the table
I mean that's just kind of I
don't know not right I'm not
an awful person at all.
But I just don't understand how
the community can rule over
comedy music and Castle people
taking the cancel culture too
far, you're going to tell you
how to take it that's what's got
them here.
And that's just going to keep
going you know we live in a he
goes after everybody.
It's not just aimed at one group
it's not as negative as people
people understand it's kind
of presenting oneself out
in the media sense and villains
getting caught into comedy
and it's just the times are
changing to where everybody is
taking things more seriously
than what they're supposed to be
about we're working to fix
America.
He has a platform to be able
to perform without powerful
and I mean so sold out obviously
it's not effective to that
definitely don't see him being
apologetic maybe he should I
think it started addressing
important issues but many people
went overboard and so now I
think society is working against
it, and it's having a bad view I
think everything's a double
edged sword there's good and bad
it's just what you know some
people are getting canceled
for doing I don't know a lot
of these people aren't bad
people either they just say one
thing 10 years ago you get
their job and their life taken
from them so camp out.